is your name Chandler yes yes it is
Chandler Bing
in this scene Chandler is approached by
an old classmate Suzy they have a short
chat where she brings up an old incident
where she felt humiliated by Chandler in
front of all the school whenever the
class play like you you pulled up my
skirt in the entire auditorium saw my
underpants however she seems to have
left the past behind and is now
interested in dating Chandler so listen
how many times am I gonna have to touch
him on the arm before you ask me my date
well let's try one more so we have
something pretty special you can get a
free PDF power lesson for this lesson
and learn all the most important
vocabulary pronunciation cultural
context and more just click up here or
in the description below to download
that and if you're new here here's how
it works you will first watch a clip
then you will learn all of the most
important vocabulary pronunciation and
cultural context before moving on to the
next clip
finally you will test your learning by
watching the scene without subtitles and
answering quiz questions the quiz is new
so please help us out by commenting
below and telling us what you thought of
it by the way if you are easily offended
you may not like this lesson and I would
recommend you instead watch one of the
lessons in the playlist linked at the
top now it's time to laugh and learn
with Julia Roberts on friends shoot we
gotta go got a reservation at 30 minutes
mm-hmm no no no no no you see what I had
planned shouldn't take more than 2-3
minutes tops
200 seconds of passion we gotta go
here's an idea have you ever worn
women's underwear
yes actually but they were my aunt
Edna's yeah three of us in there I was
kind of sexy if you wore mine tonight at
dinner you want me to wear your panties
well if I was wearing your underwear
then what would you be wearing you're
swell how come all I can think about is
putting that ice in my mouth and licking
you all over because I went to an
all-boys high school and God is making
up for it
meet me in the bathroom oh shoot we got
to go got a reservation in 30 minutes
shoot is a more polite or innocent way
to say [ __ ] [ __ ] I left my guitar in
their apartment as we've explained in
one of our recent lessons a reservation
is an arrangement you make so that a
place in a hotel restaurant plane etc is
kept for you at a particular time in the
future in this case Julie's character
has made a dinner reservation mm-hmm no
no no no no no you see what I had
planned shouldn't take more than two
three minutes tops
we say tops to mean at most we usually
use it when we're talking about time to
mean no later than or an amount of money
to mean no more than example I'll be
back by 10:00 11:00 a.m. tops I'll be
back in two hours tops
oh honey I can keep your secret forever
but just see you now can't ya I'm weak
yeah you got maybe three four days tops
look yeah hey I hope you're enjoying the
lesson so far so every week we make
lessons like this one to help you to
understand your favorite series without
subtitles just like the law who says
that since he joined his confident
speaking English and even his
performance in his master's program have
greatly increased so remember to hit
that subscribe button and the bell down
below so you don't miss any of our new
lessons do you want me to wear your
panties many times when an N is before
80 as in 20 or panties we drop the T and
pronounce 24 panties so even though the
standard pronunciation is Internet
counter you'll also hear currently some
kind of stupid internet billionaire you
smash it on the counter and he was too
embarrassed say anything in the
following clip see how Sheldon says
identify and the professor identify this
professor can you identify our cricket
of course I can I can identify every
insect and arachnid on the planet
panties is another name for women's
underwear we would not use panties to
refer to men's underwear but rather
undies now let's take a look at the
grammar in the following sentence well
if I was wearing your underwear then
what would you be wearing this is a
second conditional sentence we use this
type of conditional sentence to talk
about a hypothetical or imaginary
situation in the future for example if I
had a million dollars I would buy a big
house if I had a son I'd want them to be
like Kenneth proof you
the way we form an affirmative second
conditional sentence is following this
structure if + subject + past tense verb
subject + would + infinitive let's say
you are worth the money fine
but trust me if you told him the truth
he thanked you later they gave awards
for starting fires I'm beginning one of
those - to make a negative second
conditional sentence you just need to
say would not if I had to do it all over
again
I would change a darn thing she was
still alive I wouldn't have to be
talking to you and to make an
interrogate of second conditional
sentence you just change the position of
would bringing it before the subject
Sheldon if you were a robot and I knew
and you didn't also in questions you can
add a wh question word like what when
who etc or how before would when this
happens it's common to bring this the
result clause and put the if clause
second that's to say you can ask if you
were in my shoes what would you do or
inverting the order as in this example
well what would you do if you were in my
shoes first I give them switching the if
clause with the result clause is
possible with the affirmative and
negative second conditional sentences -
you may have noticed that in the example
from this scene it is also continuous to
be wearing well if I was wearing your
underwear then what would you be wearing
this is simply because he is referring
to a concrete although hypothetical
moment in the future rather than just a
broad and general hypothetical idea that
would be understood if he had said if I
wore your underwear what would you wear
so I wanted to take a
to tell you about a big opportunity that
we have for you up until July 20th if
you find grammar pronunciation and
vocabulary explanations like these
helpful and you enjoy our method of
making learning English fun with your
favorite series like friends
then our fluency course fluent with
friends is perfect for you you'll get
the confidence that you need to
understand the natives at any speed
without getting lost
without missing the jokes and without
subtitles just like yam but who says
that since he joined he's learning like
never before so much more than at the
academies that he studied at when you
joined flew with friends you would learn
with the 48 full episodes from the first
two seasons from friends every week you
will get a 20-plus page PDF power lesson
like this one innovative vocabulary
memorization software access to our
global fluency circle community and so
much more plus if you join these
standard or complete packages you also
get weekly video lessons teaching you
with the best scenes from each episode
that's over 56 exclusive video lessons
very similar to the ones that you find
here but you will not find these ones on
YouTube and they include over 13 hours
of materials to thank you for your
support and to celebrate over 750
thousand subscribers here at learnings
with TV series it has a part of fluency
week we are offering you a 33 percent
discount off fluent with friends you
just have to use the coupon code 700k at
checkout what would it feel like if next
year you could understand your favorite
series without subtitles or have a
conversation with an American without
having to ask her to slow down don't
wait join flow with friends now I look
forward to seeing you in the fluency
circle now let's get back to the lesson
you're swell this is another way to say
someone or something is great example
that was a swell party
he's a swell guy
obviously he thinks Uzi is great because
she has inferred that he will be wearing
her underwear so she won't be wearing
any how come all I can think about is
putting that ice in my mouth and licking
you all over because I went to an
all-boys high school and God is making
up for it how come
works like why for example you can ask
why are you late how come you're late
however there's a very subtle difference
with how come you're not just
questioning you're also expressing a
level of surprise so in why you late
you're asking for an explanation but if
a person you know is always punctual and
you're surprised she's come late to work
you would ask how come you're late
Monica's making Jam Oh Jim I love Jam
hey how come we never have jam at our
place because the kids need new shoes we
also might just say how come example I
didn't even eat lunch today really how
come Chandler's funny response to
Suzie's how come is because I went to an
all-boys high school and God is making
up for it an all-boys school is a school
where all the students are male the
opposite is an all-girls school Chandler
is not happy that he attended an
all-boys school and thinks that now God
is making up for it by putting this
woman who's very enthusiastic about
going to bed with him in his destiny so
to make up for something means to do
something with the purpose of
compensating for something okay Chandler
thank you so much no problem
listen that's a pretty girly hour we
just spent we should I would do some
manly makeup for it yeah go my Island
yeah
you could also say this if you want
someone to forget something you did that
they didn't like
I want to make up for the wrong I did to
you this is yours
alright mister let's see those panties
mmm but you know what would be even
sexier what if you didn't have your
shirt tucked into them all right now I
would like to see you wearing nothing
but them take your clothes off
okay but I hope you realize this means
we're gonna miss hearing about the
specials hey you want this done quick or
do you want it done right turn around I
would see you from behind somebody's
been doing his buns of steel videos when
chatty finger
soozee soozee this is for the fourth
grade
[Applause]
underpants mr. that's funny don't you
the fourth grade help you to still get
upset about that
well um why don't you call me in 20
years and tell me if you're still upset
hmm
but you know what would be even sexier
notice how she pronounces but you know
as but you know this is called
assimilation and it happens when a word
ends in T and the next begins with Y
this is common in rapid speech okay what
do you think I like it you don't love it
no I do I love it Joe did you stop doing
that
you really want this for him don't you
all right now I would like to see you
wearing nothing but them take your
clothes off nothing but means only she
wants to see him wearing only panties in
this expression but is used like the
word accept so nothing but means nothing
except or if given the case no one
accept or not anyone except example I
didn't tell the news to anyone but my
brother
this means that he didn't tell the news
to anyone except his brother then she
tells him to take his clothes off she's
asking him to remove his clothes like
Joey's doing in this scene okay but I
hope you realize this means we're gonna
miss hearing about the specials
in the context of dining a special is a
particularly on the menu
but is served on a particular day it's
very common for restaurants in the
United States to have rotating daily and
nightly specials if you eat at a
restaurant in the USA the waiter will
usually tell you about the specials
shortly after you sit down so this is
what Chandler is referring to somebody's
been doing his buns of steel videos buns
of steel was a popular 80's and 90's
video based workout program that focused
on toning and growing the buttocks buns
is an informal name for buttocks and
steel as a type of metal careful because
many learners overuse the word ass which
in English is considered offensive buns
or but are considered more appropriate
words how could you still be upset about
that if you're upset you're angry or
unhappy I don't want you to be upset how
could I not be upset okay I finally fall
in love with this fantastic woman and it
turns out that she wanted you first Joey
Chandler what are you still doing here I
thought you guys took over oh no she
took off with my clothes
the first time you try panties and
someone walks off with your clothes I
was not trying them out Susie asked me
to wear them
Joey some people don't like that
Chandler's wearing panties let me see oh
hi - is she
right what do you give me your
underpants can't help you I'm not
wearing anything how can you not be
wearing any underwear oh I'm getting
heat from the guy in the hot pink car
what are you still doing here I thought
you guys took over she took off with my
clothes another meaning of take off is
when we use it as a synonym of to leave
we also use this expression to announce
we're leaving as in the following clip
really yeah I'll see you soon all right
[Music]
the first time you try panties and
someone walks off with your clothes this
expression also means to leave but we
never say I'll walk off as we'd say all
take off rather we say walk off to
describe the action of someone leaving
especially in an abrupt manner example a
random guy gave me his tickets to the
game and walked off through the crowd to
floss is the action that you see here we
can imagine that Joey says he's flossing
because of how Suzie's underwear looks
on him tushy is another word for
buttocks
however it's mostly used by or with
children so it's a funny word for Ross
to use how can you not be wearing any
underwear oh I'm getting heat from the
guy in the hot pink thong to get heat
from someone means to receive criticism
example I'm gonna get heat from my boss
for being late another similar
expression is to take heat which means
to receive and endure criticism example
as part of the customer support team
she's used to taking heat from angry
customers or if you are the one
delivering the criticism you would be
giving heat example his boss gave him
heat for arriving late the joke in this
clip is that Chandler is criticizing
Joey for not wearing underwear when he
is wearing a thong all right so now it's
time for you to test everything you
learned by watching the scene a final
time without subtitles but this time
we're also throwing in a bit of a quiz
so at certain moments we will pause the
video to ask you different questions you
will have a few seconds to answer each
question before we showed the correct
answer on the screen be sure to tell us
what you thought about this because it's
the first time we're doing it and let us
know what score you got on the quiz all
right are you ready let's roll the quiz
shoot we gotta go got a reservation at
30 minutes
oh no no no no no no no you see what I
had planned shouldn't take more than two
three minutes tops
200 seconds of passion we gotta go
here's an idea have you ever worn
women's underwear well yes actually but
they were my aunt Edna's and there were
three of us in there kind of sexy if you
wore mine tonight at dinner you want me
to wear your panties Jason well if I was
wearing your underwear then
well if I was wearing your underwear
then what would you be wearing
you're swell licking you all over
because I went to an all-boys high
school and got lucky you all over
school and God is making up for it
meet me in the bathroom all right mister
let's see those panties mmm but you know
what would be even sexier what if you
didn't have your shirt tucked into them
all right now I would like to see you
wearing nothing but them take your
clothes off okay but I hope you realize
this means we're gonna miss hearing
about the specials
thank you what this done quick or do you
want done right turn around I would see
you from behind
Oh somebody's been doing his buns of
steel video what jetty finger Suzie
Suzie this is for the fourth grade what
do I mean
I mean Underpants mister that's what I
mean
don't was you the fourth grade help you
to still get upset about that well um
why don't you call me in 20 years and
tell me if you're still upset Joey
Chandler what are you still doing here I
thought you guys took over hold on
she took off with my clothes the first
time you tried panties and someone walks
off with your clothes I was not trying
them out Susie asked me to wear them
Joey some people don't like that
Chandler's wearing panties let me see
hi - she
right what do you give me underpants
can't help ya I'm not wearing anything
how can you not be wearing any underwear
oh I'm getting heat from the guy in the
hot pink car
whoops fifty dollars for your underpants
Hey all right how did you do remember to
tell us your score and what you thought
about that quiz down in the comments
below and also remember that fluency
week ends July 20th so it's a last
chance to get that 33 percent discount
on our fluent with French course so that
we can join you on your mission to speak
and understand English confidently learn
more and sign up for the course and
remember to get your 33% discount you
just have to use the coupon code 700k at
checkout now it's time to go beyond the
classroom and live your English aha yeah